et retour sur cette polémique concernant
une loi russe relatives aux vins
pétillants notre correspondante en
pierrot s'est rendu dans l'une des plus
grandes exploitations viticoles du pays
pour tenter de tirer les choses au clair
regarder au début de l'été une nouvelle
loi russe relatives à la réglementation
des boissons alcoolisées a fait les gros
titres de la presse française à les lire
on pourrait croire que la nouvelle
législation prend ouvertement et
explicitement pour cible le champagne
français alors que la réalité est
quelque peu différente
concrètement en quoi cette nouvelle loi
vient elle modifié l'étiquetage des
bouteilles françaises et bien sur
l'étiquette principale aucun changement
l'appellation champagne peut continuer à
être utilisés sans aucun problème c'est
uniquement sur l'étiquette de derrière
la contre étiquette qui est écrite
entièrement en russe donc en caractères
cyrilliques et bien l'appellation
champagne est remplacé par vin pétillant
essayons maintenant d'y voir plus clair
sur les réels objectifs de cette
nouvelle législation wen dans un combat
y est celle à houston pour une chose
concernant cette loi il y avait un
objectif est de l'autre côté ce qui
s'est vraiment passé son but était de
limiter considérablement l'usagé du
terme champagne russe pour les
producteurs des vins russe qui les
produisent selon des technologies de
base ou de qualité médiocre - patrice
norguet après ce tir est passé chez
eurogamer option
[Musique]
désormais après ces amendements le
nombre de boissons qui ont droit d'être
désigné comme champagne russe a
fortement diminué prato les
immigrés ce que j'en pense que
et le champagne français dans tout ça ce
ne serait en fait qu'un simple
malentendu
malheureusement il y un deuxième aspect
de cette loi les législateurs n'ont
probablement pas saisi cette news selon
la nouvelle réglementation le champagne
shampoing de ce courrier écrit en
caractères cyrilliques mes produits que
sur le territoire de la fédération de
russie à partir de raisins russe devrait
comprenons très bien que cela provoque
un conflit plutôt idéologique qui n'est
pas compatible avec les règles de la vie
mesures mondiales et si tout cela au
final n'était qu'une tempête dans une
coupe de champagne
en tout cas l'esprit de cette nouvelle
réglementation n'est pas temps de
déclencher une guerre commerciale contre
la france mais plutôt de fixer des
critères stricts à la filière viticole
russe et ce afin de privilégier la
qualité et le savoir-faire comme ici à
un bras ou d'urso il ya un potentiel
incroyable on a on a de la surface on a
des conditions climatiques qui sont
presque idéal on a un encépagement qui
est remarquable on est basé sur des
cépages internationaux
ç'a toujours été la stratégie de la
maison et puis on a un outil de
production qui est équipé des
technologies va pas dire les plus
modernes mais qui sont largement d'un
très bon niveau donc on peut faire des
choses remarquables moi je je me régale
tous les jours c'est un plaisir de
travailler ici en russie fiona deroff ma
femme puisque nos vignerons sont
satisfaits de la qualité des raisins ils
contrôlent totalement le processus de
maturation
prélève des échantillons sur nos
vignobles deux fois par semaine ils font
des tests en laboratoire et sur la base
de ces analyses ils font des conclusions
concernant la maturation des raisins
pour savoir s'ils sont prêts à être
cueillies sur telle ou telle autre site
en attend maintenant en charge quelques
remarques et avec cette nouvelle loi la
russie tente simplement de remettre de
l'ordre dans la production nationale de
vin et renouer ainsi avec son glorieux
passé de pays viticole depuis le début
des années 2000 on assiste en fait à un
renouveau à une renaissance du vignoble
nord renaissance un renouveau des vins
de nouveaux investisseurs de nouveaux
projets en gros il ya un redémarrage
pour moi la russie est en plein boom on
plante des milliers d'hectares tous les
ans en russie que ce soit ici en
krasnodar en crimée
daguestan
c'est une activité qui en plein
bouleversement et avec une volonté de
faire mieux de faire plus et c'est
génial quand on consommateurs russes de
champagne ce n'est sans doute pas une
inscription en petits caractères sur le
dos d'une bouteille qui va bouleverser
leurs habitudes